hey guys today I'm going to talk about
possibility of the most honorable man in
the Seven Kingdoms at our stark being
alive this whole time let me just say
that I'm not really into those theories
in which someone that is so dying is
actually alive but I came up to this
theory upon rewatching Game of Thrones
series and to me the same theory is more
than convincing I'm not going to talk
about Ned Stark working into one of the
birds that fool about them in the
execution scene or about anything that
has to do with working today I am
bringing a theory that might be the most
believable theory among big amount of
them I'm bringing a theory in which a
man that was beheaded by Sir Ilyn Payne
on the steps of the great Sept of Baelor
wasn't actually met himself but was
jocking agar baronet's face I know that
at first it probably sounds unbelievable
or even might sound ridiculous
but give me a few moments to explain it
as wellnot added upon trying to carry
out the Justice and Roberts well was
betrayed by Slynt and Baelish whereupon
he was imprisoned in black cells beneath
the red keep while at the same time
there was also jacking cigar a
mysterious man that was introducing
himself as the Loretto criminal and who
was also arrested and put in dungeons
viola wondering ever since we found out
who the Loretto criminal by the name of
jack inca gar really is a faceless man
assessing why he got himself arrested
since you know that he did it on purpose
and get himself into dungeons clearly on
purpose according to this theory of
faceless men assessing most highly paid
for his services which in this case
would be helping Ned Stark to avoid
death no it's not what your problem
thinking right now Jackie didn't switch
his face with Ned he switched it with
Syrio Forel at this point you're
probably confused which I understand but
just say for a few moments before you
decide to throw this theory way as we
all know
Syrio Forel is the master swordfighter
from the free city of Braavos hired by
Ned Stark to train his daughter Arya
upon discovering that his daughter owns
the sword upon its rest when Sir guard
led by Sir Meryn Trant of the Kingsguard
kaempffer Arya to take her into custody
a cinder
then they did Siri engaging sir Marion
meet his wooden sword but his theory
Syria didn't die as he was still far
better with his wooden sword then a
dozen slender guards along with ser
Meryn Trant
but according to this theory Syria
defeated him as the count himself left
so hard an aria statement that she
learned how to fight from the first
sword of Braavos who was apparently
killed by Sir Maron since her Marion was
an great fighter not even a good one so
at this point of theory Ned Stark and
Jackie Marin their self which matches
the Game of Thrones series while Syria
didn't die and was still in King's
Landing whereupon he decided to help
them start which could be questionable
but let's keep up with theory by this
theory
Jackie cigar was arrested on purpose
which is most likely true since I can't
imagine that a faceless man could have
been arrested against kids well arrest
which she did on purpose because of Ned
Stark in order to get into dungeons and
in order to help Ned Stark in order to
sacrifice his life for Ned's it said
that for good price a cult of religious
assassins that worship the many-faced
God will grant the gift of death to
anyone in the world but will they for
good price suffer their own life to the
many-faced God which Jackie in by this
theory there is also questionable
according to this theory
Jackie hug our faceless man created a
face that looks just like Ned's Android
on the day of Ned's be sharing which
would mean that instead of Ned it was
Jackie who died who was beheaded in
front steps of the great Sept of Baelor
as some kind of proof I'm relying on the
scene that took place in the final
episode of season 5 I've seen me jacking
her garb or his face who was standing
just beside him a scene that might have
confirmed that a faceless man assassins
can mirror face of a person that is not
dead person that is still alive since
they might be able to create a mask from
other faces that could look just like
the face of the person they want to
portray if you are wondering what a
serious role in it it's actually pretty
simple
both jacking and Ned were rested and
were in their cells which means that
while Jackie Hegar was
for training at Starke and just before
he was beheaded
someone had to release that free and
that someone also had to replace jocking
since we also jaqen H'ghar being
recruited by yearn to join the Nights
Watch at his point
Jackie replaces Loretta criminal face
with Ned's face that he created himself
violet Stark was released free from his
cell with help of Syrio Forel which
wasn't that hard not to mention
impossible since various also could have
done the same if he wanted as he replied
on that question if he could release him
with yes I could but will I know let's
see what we got so far
Jackie knees beheaded Ned Stark is set
free but who took jack is former face of
the Loretto criminal and continuing to
portray him as he saw him being
recruited by urine and as we saw am
helping arya numerous times it could be
and by this theory it is Syrio Forel
which we already might have a
confirmation from a scene in the jack in
said to arya there is only one god and
you know his name let me highlight one
part of sentence that Jackie told her
and you know his name which might but
only might confirm that Syria to face of
faceless man that died for Ned took a
face of jacking her gar which would
explain why Jack in total area that she
knows God's name which she knew because
Siri already told her during their
training serious said to her there's
only one God and His name is death if
this theory comes true in the upcoming
season or more likely in the last eight
season it would also explain why Jackie
was so protective towards Arya and why
he learned her to become a skilled
fighter
it will also explain how Jackie knew
that RA already knows the name of one
true God and the most importantly why
Jackie cigar was smiling when Arya said
to him a girl is Arya Stark from
Winterfell and I'm going home upon
rereading the books I've also found some
kind of a hidden hints that are going
favor to this theory in rejecting more
Nets face and was beheaded first skin
would be senseless claim that your
father scared about maegor's holdfast
looked really unlike her father and the
second
we'll be Kaitlin stamen that meds bones
don't look like nads but rather like
someone smaller than that and alas turd
he and would be re estate man that net
on execution they looked different which
he thinks was a result of Ned's injury
that he got from his confrontation with
Jamie but let's face it wounded leg
doesn't change your facial features I
know that there are still a few
unanswered questions such as who paid
the faceless man and various net hiding
this whole time which could be very
simple considering a scene from the very
first season a scene in which various
visited imprisoned Ned from that scene
for the very first and for the last time
is so very selling at some one which he
did because he cared about Ned's life
but from that scene we have also found
out from where is that he was living in
the Free Cities the importance of those
facts that I brought you a moment ago is
that very scared for Nets life he didn't
really snap himself because of a simple
reason everyone would have known it was
him which gave very suddenly one choice
which is to pay to the faceless man for
his services while Syrio Forel either
decided on his own to help Ned or was
arranged by various as well now let's
try to solve occasion on which net might
have gone upon being released my first
guess would be the free series to be
more detailed the free city of Pentos to
be even more detailed as a guest of
Illyria mo Paris very says Lowell friend
there's also possibility of Ned Stark
upon being released stayed in Westeros
more precisely in Rey would watch the
seat of house Reid who's had is Howland
Reed next little friend that has already
saved his life once and the only man
that decide Ned knows an escaping John
Stehr identity in secret I know that
this theory might sound inaccurate but
after all that we have seen and after
all the showrunners brought and
surprised a sweat this theory might but
only might come true also if you're
wondering why am i rejecting possibility
of Ned Stark being able to work into one
of the birds that fool above them in the
execution scene well let's just put it
this way apparently the most important
or should I say
the only argument that goes in favor to
the working theory is men start being
seen muttering to himself a moment
before he was beheaded now in my opinion
the working theory is ridiculous in my
opinion it was either the actual net who
measured himself the same praise that he
was muttering just a moment before he
executed well a deserter from the Nights
Watch or if you remind at a variety
today comes true it would mean that
Jackson while wearing its face muttered
to himself all men must die in
conclusion I'm not saying the theory
that I brought you today will surely
come true but it certainly is an
interesting theory let me know your
opinion about all of this in the comment
section down below hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see in the next one peace
[Music]
you